former malaysian prime minister najib
razak arrives in court for his appeal
hearing
last july he was found guilty of
illegally receiving about 10 million
dollars
from src international which was linked
to the state-owned investment fund 1mdb
the amount in this appeal is small
compared to the 1 billion
prosecutors say he's received from the
funds
najib who's been convicted on 7 charges
and still faces
35 more has denied all wrongdoings
i think his lawyers will argue that
number one he did not intend upon
those money coming in and number two if
they were coming in
uh then the the amounts of money would
be political contribution
last year najib said under oath just
before he was sentenced
he wasn't aware the money in his
accounts had come from src
international his lawyers argued during
the trial
he had been misled by a fugitive
financier low-tech joe
into believing the money was part of a
donation from the saudi royal family
the trial judge had dismissed the
defense argument describing it
as far-fetched the 1mdb financial
scandal
played a major role in bringing down
najib's party and its coalition
in a general election in 2018.
investigators say more than four and a
half billion dollars
were stolen from one mdb if he loses
this appeal najib still has a final
chance to challenge the conviction at
malaysia's top
court florence louis al jazeera kuala
lumpur